[Musique]
on
oh
donc aujourd'hui nous allons voir un
chapitre d'histoire sur l'antiquité
grecque donc vous pouvez prendre votre
stylo rouge est noté sur votre cahier
jeu monsieur excusez moi d'être à l'aise
en retard bonjour jouanard c'est depuis
le début de la semaine ça fait trois
fois que tu es en retard bien allez vas
t'asseoir à ta place
les autres donc vous noté chapitre iii
d'histoire l'antiquité grecque
il ya de ces noté en deux pages au stylo
rouge bien donc nous avons noté le titre
du chapitre iii donc l'antiquité grecque
donc la période que l'on va étudier
c'est le 5e siècle avant jésus-christ
[Musique]
le donc 5e siècle avant jésus-christ
donc on va parler plus particulièrement
d'une cité grecque la cité d'athènes et
nous allons pouvoir dans ce chapitre est
bien la vie quotidienne
[Musique]
mais si vous fermez le ban
ou alors c'est comme ça qu'on coupe in
tomates c'est très simple à l'ex homme
tu veux couper tu veux ça près regarde
c'est très sain ces derniers mois comme
à nouveau les trahir il faut piquer la
tomate la coupe et la repique et l'a
recoupé
[Musique]
moins de trois dixièmes par ci par là
alors c'est vraiment un kebab d'origine
réunionnaise
c'est vraiment un kebab délicieux
[Musique]
alors qu'un de judicaël tu veux un kebab
donc parlons maintenant de
l'alimentation des grecs
alors de quoi se compose de
j'honore des kebabs il mange des kebabs
[Applaudissements]
on
on est